the jogan experience and wondering what
the potential for the future is and
whether or not that's a good
thing I think it's going to be a great
thing but I think it's not going to be
all a great thing and that that is
where I think that's where all of the
complexity comes in for people it's not
this like clean story of we're going to
do this and it's all going to be great
it's we're going to do this it's going
to be net great but it's going to be
like a technological Revolution it's
going to be a societal Revolution and
those always come with change and even
if it's like net wonderful you know
there's things we're going to lose along
the way some kinds of jobs some kind
parts of our way of life some parts of
the way we live are going to change or
go away
and no matter how tremendous the upside
is there and and I believe it will be
tremendously good you know there's a lot
of stuff we got to navigate through to
make sure
um
that's that's a complicated thing for
for anyone to wrap their heads around
and there's you know deep and super
understandable emotions around that
that's a very honest answer that it's
not all going to be good but it seems
inevitable at this point it's yeah I
mean it's definitely inevitable my my
view of the world you know when you're
like a kid in school you learn about
this technological Revolution and then
that one and then that one and my view
of the world now sort of looking
backwards and forwards is that this is
like one long technological Revolution
and we had sure like first we had to
figure out agriculture so that we had
the resources and time to figure out how
to build machines then we got this
Industrial Revolution and that made us
learn about a lot of stuff a lot of
other scientific discovery too let us do
the computer Revolution and that's now
letting us as we scale up to these
massive systems do the AI Revolution but
it really is just one long story of
humans discovering science and
technology and co-evolving with it and I
think it's the most exciting story of
all time I think it's how we get to this
world of abundance and
although you know although we do have
these things to navigate and there there
will be these downsides if if you think
about what it means for the world and
for people's quality of lives if we can
get to a world uh where the the cost of
intelligence and the abundance that
comes with that
uh the cost dramatically Falls the
abundance goes ways up goes way up I
think we'll do the same thing with
energy and I think those are the two
sort of key inputs to everything else we
want so if we can have abundant and
cheap energy and
intelligence that will transform
people's lives largely for the better
and I think it's going to in the same
way that if we could go back now 500
years and look at someone's life we'd
say well there there's some great things
but they didn't have this they didn't
have that can you believe they didn't
have modern medicine that's what people
are going to look back at us like but in
50 years when you think about the people
that currently rely on jobs that AI will
replace when you think about whether
it's truck drivers or automation workers
people that work in Factory assembly
lines what if anything what strategies
can be put to mitigate the negative
downsides of those jobs being eliminated
by
AI
so I'll talk about some general thoughts
but I I find making very specific
predictions difficult because the way
the technology goes has been so
different than even my own intuitions or
certainly my own intuitions can we maybe
we should stop there and back up a
little what we what were your initial
thoughts if you had asked me 10 years
ago I would have said first AI is going
to come for bluecollar labor basically
it's going to drive trucks and do
factory work and you know it'll handle
heavy machinery then maybe after that
it'll do like some kinds of cognitive
Labor uh kind of you know but not it
won't be off doing what I think of
personally as the really hard stuff it
won't be off proving new mathematical
theorems won't be off you know
discovering new science um won't be offw
writing code and then eventually maybe
but maybe last of all maybe never
because human creativity is this magic
special special thing last of all it'll
come for the creative jobs that's what I
would have said now a it looks to me
like and for a while AI is much better
at doing tasks than doing jobs it can do
these little pieces super well but
sometimes it goes off the rails uh it
can't keep like very long coherence so
people are instead just able to do their
existing jobs way more productively um
but you really still need the human
there today and then B it's going the
exactly the other direction could do the
Creative work first stuff like coding
second they can do things like other
kinds of cognitive labor third and we're
the furthest away from like humanoid
robots
H so back to the initial
question if we do have something that
completely eliminates uh Factory workers
completely
eliminates truck drivers delivery
drivers things on those lines that
creates this massive vacuum in our
society so I think there's things that
we're going to do that are good to do
but not sufficient so I think at some
point we will do something like a Ubi or
some other kind of like very long-term
unemployment insurance something but
we'll have some way of giving people
like redistributing money in society a
as a cushion for people as people figure
out the new jobs but and I maybe I
should touch on that I I'm not a
Believer at all that there won't be lots
of new jobs I I think human creativity
desire for status wanting different ways
to compete invent new things feel part
of a community feel valued uh that's not
going to go anywhere people have worried
about that forever what happens is we
get better tools and we just invent new
things and more amazing things to do and
there's a big universe out there and and
I think I mean that like literally uh in
that there's like Space is really big
but also there's just so much stuff we
can all do if we do get to this world of
abundant intelligence where you can sort
of just think of a new idea and it it
gets created but
but again that doesn't to the point we
started with that that that doesn't
provide like great soless to people who
are losing their jobs today so saying
there's going to be this great
indefinite stuff in the future people
are like what are we doing today so you
know we I think we will as a society do
things like Ubi and other ways of
redistribution but I don't think that
gets at the core of what people want I
think what people want is like agency
self determination the ability to play a
role in architecting the future along
with the rest of society the ability to
express themselves and create something
meaningful to them
and also I think a lot of people work
jobs they hate and I think there's we as
a society are always a little bit
confused about whether we want to work
more or work less but but
somehow
that we all get to do something
something meaningful and we all get to
play our role in driving the future
forward that's really important and what
I hope is as those truck driving Long
Haul truck driving jobs go away which
you know people have been wrong about
predicting how fast that's going to
happen but it's going to happen um we
figure out not just a way
to solve the economic problem by like
giving people the equivalent of money
every month but that there's a way that
and and we have a lot of ideas about
this there's a way that we like share
ownership and decision- making over the
future um I thing I say a lot about AGI
is that everyone everyone realizes we're
going to have to share the benefits of
that but we also have to share like the
decision making over it and access to
the system itself like I'd be more
excited about a world where we say
rather than give everybody on earth like
one eight billionth of the AGI money
which we should do that too we say you
get like eight billionth of a 1 18
billionth slice of the system you can
sell it to somebody else you can sell it
to a company you can pull it with other
people you can use it for whatever
creative Pursuit you want you can use it
to figure out how to start some new
business um and with that you get sort
of
like a voting right over how this is all
going to be used and so the better the
AGI gets the more your little one 18
billionth ownership is is worth to you
we were joking around the other day on
the podcast where I was saying that what
we need is an AI government that we we
should have ai president and have ai run
make all the decisions yeah have
something that's completely unbiased
absolutely rational has the accumulated
knowledge of the entire human history at
its disposal including all knowledge of
psychology and psychological study
including Ubi because that comes with a
host of you know pitfalls and and and
issues that people have with it so I'll
say something there um I think we're
still very far away from a system that
is capable enough and reliable enough
that you that any of us would want that
but I'll tell you something I love about
that someday let's say that thing gets
built the fact that it can go around and
talk to every person on Earth understand
their exact preferences at a very deep
level you know how they think about this
issue and that one and how they balance
the trade-offs and what they want and
then understand all of that and and like
collect itively optimize optimized for
the collective preferences of humanity
or of citizens of the US that's awesome
as long as it's not co-opted right our
government currently is co-opted that's
for sure we we know for sure that our
government is heavily influenced by
special
interests if we could have an artificial
intelligence government that has no
influence nothing has influence on it
what a fascinating idea it's possible
and I think it might be the only way
where you're going to get completely
objective the absolute most intelligent
decision for virtually every problem
every dilemma that we Face currently in
society would you truly be comfortable
handing over like final decision making
and say all right AI you got it from
here no but I'm not comfortable doing
that with anybody you know I mean I
don't I was uncomfortable with the
Patriot Act I'm uncomfortable with you
know many decisions that that are being
made it's just there's so much obvious
evidence that decisions that are being
made are not being made in the best
interest of the overall well of the
people it's being made in the decisions
of
whatever gigantic corporations that have
donated to what whatever the
military-industrial complex and
pharmaceutical industrial complex and
and then so just the money it's that's
really what we know today that money has
a massive influence on on our society
and the choices that get made and the
overall good or bad for the population
yeah I I have no disagreement at all
that the current system is super broken
not working for people super corrup
corrupt and for sure like unbelievably
run by money yeah a and I think there is
a way to do a better job than that with
AI to in some way but and this might
just be like a factor of sitting with
the systems all day and watching all of
the ways they fail we got a long way to
go a long way to go I'm sure but when
you think of AGI when you think of the
possible future like where it goes to do
you ever extrapolate do you do you ever
like sit and pause and say well if this
if this becomes sensient and it has the
ability to make better versions of
itself how long before we're literally
dealing with a God so the way that I
think about this is it used to be that
like AGI was this very binary moment it
was before and after and I think I
totally wrong about that and the right
way to think about it is this Contin
Continuum of intelligence this smooth
exponential curve back all the way to
that sort of smooth curve curve of
technological Revolution the the amount
of compute power we can put into the
system the scientific ideas about how to
make it more efficient and smarter to
give it the ability to do reasoning to
think about how to improve itself that
will all come but my my model for a long
time I I think if you look at the world
of AGI thinkers there's uh there's sort
of two particularly around the safety
issues you're talking about there's two
axes that matter there's the short what
called short timelines or long timelines
you know to the first Milestone of AGI
whatever that's going to be is that
going to happen in a few years a few
decades maybe even longer although at
this point I think most people are a few
years or few decades and then there's
takeoff speed once we get there from
there to that point you were talking
about where it's capable of the rapid
self-improvement um is that a slow or a
fast process the the world that I think
we're heading that we're in and also the
world that I think is the most
controllable and the safest is the short
timelines and slow takeoff quadrant
and I think we're going to have
you know there were a lot of very smart
people for a while who were like the
thing you were just talking about
happens in a day or three days and I
don't that doesn't seem likely to me
given the shape of the technology as we
understand it now now even if that
happens in a decade or three decades
it's still like the blink of an eye from
a historical perspective
and there are going to be some real
challenges to getting that right and the
decisions we
make the the sort of safety system
and the and the checks that the world
puts in place how we think
about global regulation or rules of the
road from a safety perspective for those
projects it's super important because
you can imagine many things going
horribly wrong but I've
been I feel cheerful about the progress
the world is making towards taking this
seriously and uh you know it reminds me
of what I've read about the
conversations that the world had right
around the development of nuclear
weapons